what we're going to do in this video is
talk a lot about money and in particular
we're going to talk about the market for
money and this might seem a little bit
counterintuitive because we're used to
thinking about the market in other
things and we use money as a way to
think about price we use money as a way
to facilitate transactions but now the
market is money itself so the first
question is how do we somehow come up
with a cost of money and to help us with
that i'll give you a little bit of a
thought experiment let's say that we had
a very very simple world where you had
two options
you could have your cash money you could
have a hundred dollars in cash just like
that or you could lend that hundred
dollars to the government and the
government would pay you back in a month
one hundred and one dollars so your
other option we'll call that a bond
a bond which is really your lending in
this situation you are lending this
money to the government let's assume
that it is risk-free that the government
is good for the money you can also have
bonds where you're lending to other
entities like states or to corporations
but let's say that this is a federal
government bond and in one month
it costs a hundred dollars
it costs
and in one month
in one month
the government will pay back
government
pays
back
so my question to you is what if you
decide instead of buying this bond and
then having the government pay you back
in a month for 101 instead of that if
you decide hey you know what that sounds
interesting but i just like the feel of
of cash what is the opportunity cost of
holding the cash
pause the video and think about that
well if you decide to hold this cash
instead of buying this government bond
instead of lending it to the government
for that month you are foregoing one
dollar so your opportunity cost right
over here you could view it as one
dollar over
over the month
or if you think about it in terms of how
much money this is you have a one
percent opportunity cost
opportunity
opportunity cost
and as we are about to see we think
about the opportunity cost of holding
the money as its cost in the money
market so let me draw some axes here to
start thinking about this this this
money market
all right so let's call this vertical
axis the nominal interest rate
nominal
interest
rate sometimes you'll see
n i r it's abbreviated but let's just
write it out the nominal interest rate
in that in that axis and the reason why
i'm focusing on the nominal interest
rate is we don't know in this situation
what inflation is we don't know how to
calculate the real interest rate in this
situation and that's what people look at
when they're making these decisions
people aren't constantly calculating the
real interest rate because they know
exactly what inflation is in exactly
that moment they can just see hey i
could either keep this hundred dollars
in my pocket or i could lend it to the
government and a month later get a
hundred and one dollars so we're going
to have the nominal interest rate on
this axis right over here and then in
the horizontal axis
i am going to have the quantity of money
quantity
of
money and there's multiple ways of
thinking about which measure of money
supply and we're going to think about
that in future videos but we'll get to
that in a second the first thing i want
to do is construct a demand curve for
money
so let me ask you a question
if nominal interest rates are really
high so instead of getting a hundred one
dollars back after a month if you were
to get i'll say something extreme if you
were to get 200 back in a month
would that would you want to keep a lot
of money or would you say hey no i would
rather lend that money to the government
well yes common sense would tell you is
if the nominal interest rate is quite
high then people will perhaps choose to
forego holding the money and so the
quantity of money might be lower
so we might be in a situation
like this high nominal interest rate hey
that's a high opportunity cost from
holding this cash i might want to lend
it to the government or to somebody else
now what if the nominal interest rate
were really low let's say the government
says hey you let me borrow a hundred
dollars right now in a month i will give
you a hundred dollars and a tenth of a
penny well then you're like gee that
doesn't make a lot of sense i would
really like to keep my hundred dollars i
might need it i might need to do some
transactions with it i
might want it to be around in case the
atm system goes out whatever you know
there's a hurricane whatever it might be
and so at a low nominal interest rate it
makes sense that people would want to
hold or more likely to hold their cash
and so you would have a higher quantity
of money and so that explains why
economists assume often abbreviated as
md so this is the demand curve for money
is downward sloping and if we wanted to
get a little bit more technical some
terms that you might see in an economics
class the famous economist john maynard
keynes came up with three particular
motives for this downward sloping curve
some of which i've already talked about
the first he calls the transactions
motive
transactions
and that's the idea that one of the
primary reasons you would want to keep
cash is well you might need to use it if
you want to go buy a candy bar or
buy a pet iguana that you want that
money around if you have it lent to the
government and then all of a sudden you
see your dream iguana then you have to
wait a month in order to do it so that
would be your transactions motive
a reason a motivation to hold money but
once again the reason why we have this
downward sloping curve if if nominal
interest rates are really high if the
government is willing to pay you a lot
back in a month then you might say you
know what i'm willing to take the risk
even if i see that dream iguana if i
lend the money to the government now in
a month i might be able to buy two
iguanas even if they aren't quite my
dream iguana and likewise if nominal
interest rates go really down you're
saying you know it's not worth it for me
to risk not being able to buy that
perfect iguana when it shows up so i'm
not going to lend it to the government
and so the overall quantity of money
more people are going to keep cash in
their pockets
now another motive that keynes talks
about is the precautionary motive
and this is the idea that you might want
to just keep cash around in case there's
an emergency let's say the lights go out
there's an earthquake there's a
hurricane the atm system goes out maybe
there's a banking holiday for some
reason and you're going to need some of
that cash for transactions but once
again it's more precautionary for that
rainy day for that bad situation and
once again if nominal interest rates are
high then you might say well yeah i want
to be cautious but boy i could get a lot
back if i lend that money but if nominal
interest rates are low you're like you
know it's not worth it i'd rather keep
some more money and a lot of people do
this and so that's why in general in
that economy you're going to have a high
quantity of money now the last motive
that keynes talked about is the
speculative motive
and speculation in general is this idea
of buying something or selling something
or waiting to buy something based on
some speculation you have about whether
the price will go up or down and so for
example you might say hey if i wait a
couple of days or if i might wait a week
the government might give me even a
better deal so let me hold on to this
and in aggregate when interest rates are
high nominal interest rates are high
people might be willing to forego the
ability to speculate and when interest
rates are low they might say you know
what i i'm just going to keep my cash
for now because there's not a lot to be
gained by lending that money